O Holy night, the stars are brightly shining,
It is the night of our dear Savior's birth
Long lay the world in sin and error pining
Til He appeared and the soul felt its worth
A thrill of hope the weary world rejoices
For yonder breaks a new and glorious morn
Fall on your knees
O hear the angel voices
O night divine!
O night when Christ was born
O night, o night divine!
Led by the light of faith serenely beaming,
With glowing hearts by His cradle we stand.
Led by a star above them brightly gleaming,
appeared the wise men from far Eastern land
The King of kings lay in a lowly manger;
to us this day is born to be our God:
Fall on your knees
O hear the angel voices
O night divine
O night when Christ was born
O night divine, O night
O night divine!